ça chante pas elle alors si vous
découvrez sache albaz il a émergé
pendant la crise du coc vide
non mais c'est vrai bergé c'est vraiment
c'est énorme c'est une bactérie tatata
émergé lors de cette il ya eu lui raul
mais exactement c'est vrai c'est
l'énergie
ces deux styles deux ambiances voilà non
mais ça y est voilà c'est comme une
maison et il regarde toutes les
coulisses et il a les coulisses du
pilote oui parce que lundi qu'en fait tu
viens me tu viens de dire tout ce qui
s'est passé
et oui je suis l'indiquent de la rédac
je surveille tout je regarde tout et
puis je viens vous balancer des petits
trucs coisy m'ont jamais c'est comme mon
petit cousin
oui ça ce n'est pas de ma famille il
devra j'avais l'argent c'est un problème
donc oui j'ai surveillé pour vous le
pilote cette semaine cyril parce que
tout le pilote est bien alors pour ceux
qui ne savent pas ce que c'est le pilote
d'abord c'est une émission test quand
même il faut il faut le dire
à lire à 10h attend folie où on teste
les nouveaux chroniqueurs ou en test des
nouvelles rubriques mais aussi on teste
le nouveau plateau jusque là cette année
on a un plateau quand même qui est
magnifique
bon et bien on a testé nouveau plateau
et cyril alors on sait que vous êtes un
très bon présentateur je vous l'apprends
pas vous êtes un très bon producteur je
vous l'apprends pas non plus mais elle
va se corser je sais plus mais non mais
non non parce que on a vu plus vous rend
convertir dans quoi en directeur
artistique non ainsi vous avez un avis
surtout très bien trancher si vous êtes
méchants avec moi pas du tout je vais
sortir votre surnom ou là ça me fait
peur on va regarder le sms un ami on
peut regarder le magnéto et puis on
comme ça c'est un hobby toi allez on
regarde un chaton folie
[Musique]
les mecs je veux voir ce que ça donne à
l'antenne ça fait pas access laisser les
chroniqueurs à l'huile en faire trop
vous faites mal mais nous nous était n'y
est pas et allumer tous les mecs non non
ça va pas le sol comme ça est tous là
les mecs là on est heureux il est deux
heures du matin là c'est chasse est
excellent ça va pas aller vous allez me
mettre du noir ici du gland ici ça non
ça c'est bourdon vous allez rendre à
bourdin voulu donner dans la matinale et
c'est tout je le pousse je le pousse et
poussines viatte vous voyez que je passe
par l'homme passait pas c'était vraiment
de ma gueule
arrêtez de me mettre ce fond noir je
vois le fond noir je bouffe a qu'une
importe lequel
ça peut tomber sur toi sa boss d'ea je
suis né à bâle c'est tombé sur personnes
n'ont pas très bien c'est une bonne
nouvelle bête je suis trop nouveau pour
témoigner lot on a testé le plateau mais
avait testé des nouveaux chroniqueurs
ayez une nouvelle recrue qui s'appelle
vincent perrot bien sûr à ce niveau
c'est bon mais avance on vous l'avait
recruté quand même pour ses qualités
d'animateur d'expérience dans les reee
diable c'est un grand homme des médias
mais est-ce que ça je n'y ai pas trop
recruté pour l'humour suis quand même
parce que parfois il ya des des petits
trucs un peu bizarres quoi un peu
vincent vincent perché regarde ça que
toi ça et de toi ça oui
alors moi j'aime pas cyril mais je
reconnais qu'il ya de temps en temps des
répliques qui deviennent cultes
immédiatement moi quand j'entends un
garçon pour essayer de plaire à la fille
qui dit moi je fais la cuisine et elle
est évidemment lully mais tu fais quoi
je sais faire cuire un cordon bleu tu
fais des sauces aussi away et tu fais
comment strauss tomates
j'ouvre une boîte ah ouais ouais ouais
bien maman ouais ils font une espèce des
preuves sur la plage et le gars doit
porter la fille sur ses épaules
et là elle a cette rubrique formidable
et j'espère qu'il a son permis poids
lourd pour porter un semi-remorque comme
moi c'était pas tu vas nous raconter des
émissions je pense que voilà il ya du
taf la série lh g laurence boccolini au
téléphone qui me dit kelly vous êtes le
maillon faible au revoir
tu as pas besoin de comics dont
l'émission de vincent perrot alive a été
un amour de mecs et qui sera avec nous
la semaine prochaine wi lan du pilote
détester d'autres personnes comme
laurent barak est un ami de te faire
demain avec on va faire un castaldi et
oui à une énorme carte aux eaux calmes
exactement qui sera aussi avec nous
bientôt qui prépare un jeu et qu'on voit
là bas il l'a fait question pour un
balcon par un confinement était venu
comme ça et puis bah les deux ils ont
testé un petit jeu pendant pendant le
pilote laurent barat à mon avis il a
battu un record celui du gars qui est
resté le plus longtemps
[Musique]
mecheri toi tu es tout contre et ouais
non non non mais je sais pas il ya
tellement de nouveaux outils qu'on les
connaît pas l'incroyable présentateur va
animer l'émission la france a un
incroyable talent eh bien je dirais
l'abbé julien courbet depuis cette
séquence nous sommes restés sans
nouvelles de laurent barat l'équipe de
production du souhaite bonne chance pour
la suite
salut mon pote
[Musique]
mais cette fois cet tags ah le pauvre
europe donc il sera avec benjamin demain
et j'embrasse fort laurent qui a
beaucoup de talent on y tient énormément
vous avez testé des dames en syrie n'y a
pas que laurent batsch il y avait des
dames et les dames il a chopé maxime
géniteur
je veux une limitation il ya eu juliette
longuet ah oui oui qui exercent sur
paris première qui va venir et qui était
très bien alors à la tester une
chronique sur la mode
jusqu'ici tout va bien pour une émission
médias j'ai gardé longuet bâle a testé
sa chronique est franchement sans van
mol dont ça s'est plutôt bien passé je
sens maintenant pas du tout non non je
vais te péter la gueule on est comme une
fois par semaine à sa une
je ne sais pas tu m'aimes tu m'aimes
dire ça j'ai ça sera tous les jours
alors j'ai envie de vous parler de
quelque chose dont il a fait trop brics
et sur what's in your tout ce qui va
être hype fun drôle innovants on a envie
de savoir où aller
j'adore me dire que juliette est très
sympathique oui je suis un vrai cheval
et sympathique à la quelque chose après
c'est la chronique il va falloir qu'on
chante moi ça coûtait moins 15000
j'adore si l'on suit la fin vendredi
chez castaldi c'est moi qui paye quoi
[Applaudissements]
sert il à dire car embarquer une
dernière chose sur le pilote c'est quoi
et bien c'est vous vous êtes une
personne très sympa et que vos équipes
même quand à vouzan des combattants de
travailler ensemble
ça fait deux ans t'es content pas du
tout deux japonais très sympa je vais le
voir au bureau tous les matins oui je
fais le tour comme ça et j'espère les
ordinateurs de tout ça cassez vous
faites mais à chaque fois les châles
base il fait jour quand je passe fait
genre elle est tellement occupée qui
veut pas me regarder comme non je ne
sais pas je suis là tu vois chaque jour
une ferme mito est en train de bosser
sur un trône et parce qu'une prostituée
sur un bon doit donc bien pendant le
pilote aussi ça s'est vérifié puisque
l'on vous avez pas vu les chroniqueurs
pendant deux mois et une chose est sûre
c'est ce qu'ils vous ont manqué les
conneries c'est vrai il est très content
de les revoir ah oui alors
c'est le retour de cyril un amour de
patron on va vous êtes arba mais regarde
[Musique]
la onzième saison de touche pas à mon
poste et regarder nouveau plateau ça
formica véritable sa benhaim ces juifs
c'est beau ça
il faut qu'on parle tout de suite
normalement quand on revient de vacances
on est hyper serait pourquoi toi faire
tu reviens de vacances on a l'impression
que tu as passé deux mois à lariboisière
et qu'ils devraient me soumettre à
l'opération s'est bien passée
enfin vous est splendide merci ça me
fait rigoler là à côté c'est du rêve au
cauchemar
[Rires]
cet été quatre jours en espagne et puis
je n'ai jamais été aussi draguer de ma
vie sur et amicaux noces non non c'est
non ça s'est passé ça allait partir le
chercher la première petite amie drucker
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais dû me disent ah ben non sent
bon le total
[Musique]
bravo bonjour merci sache elbaz merci à
bientôt